foreign
everyone my name is Dr Miller and the
SCP we're going to be looking at today
is SCP
4036 object class counter
special containment procedures
scp-4036 is to be surrounded by a
perimeter covering 120 000 kilometers
squared maintained by the foundation
Navy in collaboration with United
Nations peacekeeping troops in order to
prevent any
scp-4036-1 instances or trade coming in
or out of the perimeter if objects are
persons attempt to penetrate the
perimeter they are to be neutralized and
their remains relocated to site 4 in
Indonesia Foundation operatives are to
infiltrate political military religious
and cultural institutions on scp-4036
these operatives are to acquire
information on ongoing Affairs potential
operations against the foundation and
subvert potential operations within
scp-4036 at all times at least 2 percent
of the population of scp-4036 is to be
made up of foundation operatives or
scp-4036-1 instances loyal to the
foundation
in the case of a mass scale military
operation against the foundation from
scp-4036 operation Black Lily is to be
enacted operation Black Lily is to only
be enacted in the possibility that a
scp-4036 can no longer be contained
without an XE lifted Veil scenario B
that large areas of land will not be
returned to their respective countries
and see
scp-4036 will route Foundation forces in
such a way that it leaves the foundation
completely defenseless
at the time the president of scp-4036's
attitude towards the foundation has been
conciliatory lacking any hostility
characteristic of previous
administrations or governments
however due to the current atmosphere
regarding the foundation and the
possibility that the president will be
ousted before any permanent solution can
be established diplomatic relationships
have remained the same special
containment procedures have remained in
place in the possibility that an
anti-foundation president and
legislative group take control over the
governmental apparatus
description
scp-4036 is a small unitary Theocratic
Republic located in an archipelago in
the southeastern region of Polynesia 300
kilometers in radius and 100
000 kilometers squared in area
scp-4036's citizens refer to it as the
adatite Republic of Polynesia it was
previously under the autocratic rule of
Person of Interest 432 Norman Taylor
from 1857 to 1862 before his
assassination by foundation-backed
groups in the region prior to this
scp-4036 was highly militaristic
combining Industrial Age Technology with
biological Weaponry to create a
mobilized military
scp-4036 had controlled around 30
percent of Polynesia with the majority
of its Holdings in sparsely populated
locations current authorities of
scp-4036 have disavowed its founder
Person of Interest 432 and previous
imperialist ambitions
scp-4036's population is primarily
anomalous with current estimates ranging
from 50 to 80 percent government
statistics State around 64 percent of
the population is anomalous although due
to a lack of peer review it is unknown
if this is representative of the
Island's population the population is
primarily capable of Flesh manipulation
scp-4036's State religion is sarcasm
with official statistics claiming that
all of
scp-4036-1 are adherence to sarcasm
despite there being small Christian and
Islamic groups within the country
freedom of religion is allowed under the
Constitution although most non-sarkic
instances Worship in sacred to prevent
social and political ostracization
scp-4036's Society is primarily rural
with a few Central urban areas which the
majority of the population lives these
Urban locations vary from Standard
Concrete to biological buildings
economically scp-4036 is built around
animal and human agriculture
manufacturing and tobacco forming trade
is impossible due to ongoing containment
of scp-4036
scp-4036 is government controls 60
percent of the economy while the rest is
owned either communally or by
individuals
scp-4036's government is divided into
three branches executive legislative and
judicial the legislative branch is
divided into three houses the House of
Representatives the Senate and the
carcass Council the House of
Representatives currently comprises
around 100 Representatives each one
representing 100 people the Senate is
composed of 10 delegates each
representing 1 000 people both houses
are chosen by majority vote per District
the carcass council is a group of 20
individuals representing the main
religious governing body the church of
the Republic of which all citizens are
members this house is made up of
individuals hand selected by the carcass
a bill can be made into law in one of
two ways
a be approved by 60 of both the Senate
and the House of Representatives
or B be approved of by the carcass
council with a majority vote even if one
house unanimously rejects The Proposal
the executive branch is made up of a
president elected by popular vote and
their cabinet both serving five-year
terms with no chance for re-election all
cabinet positions must be approved of by
the carcass Council in majority vote or
by 60 percent of both the Senate and the
house the judicial branch makes up the
Supreme Court of the Republic composed
of six posts all for life this is made
up of appointees chosen by the president
and approved of by a simple majority in
the Senate and the house
scp-4036's Society is a combination of
proto-sarkic beliefs and modernity with
a heavy focus on religion and Civic
patriotism and modern technology
religiosity of grand carcass ion is
highly valued by the public along with
technological innovation electronic and
digital products are popular amongst
scp-4036-1 with the majority of them
coming from either smuggling or
bootlegging however biological Machinery
is also used by the populace primarily
among lower classes biological Machinery
is often viewed as inferior to digital
and electronic technology and is usually
used when non-biological options are not
available often lower classes are
incapable of buying products resorting
to crafting their own
while social stratification exists in
scp-4036's society every individual is
entitled to adequate health care and
food Healthcare is comparatively the
cheapest in the entire world however
this is most likely due more to the
abundance of biological manipulation and
crafting among the population than to
any inherent superiority of the
government Health Care system
participation in the armed forces or
civil duty is mandatory once a citizen
reaches the age of 19. individuals must
either spend time in the armed forces
for two years before being discharged or
participate in civil Duty for 16 months
most citizens choose the latter option
patriotic and religious feelings often
coincide with one another in the
cultural depictions of scp-4036 clavagar
sarn is often heavily associated with
Lady additum the personification of
scp-4036 prayer often occurs directly
after a salute to the flag of scp-4036
every president of scp-4036 has cited a
strong belief in sarcasm the majority of
scp-4036-1 hold the belief that an
individual cannot be a citizen of
scp-4036 without also being a sarcic the
military of scp-4036 often uses the Seal
of clavigor oroch the clavagar of war
and domination
currently scp-4036 has been contained to
around 300 islands and not allowed to
expand Beyond these borders while no
treaty or cooperative agreement has been
established between the foundation and
scp-4036 there have been no further
attempts by either side to Cease the
stalemate
Person of Interest file number 432 legal
name Norman Taylor Alias is used
President Taylor Associated groups of
Interest Polynesian sarkic Associated
Person of Interest Person of Interest
182 William Walker Person of Interest
433 ohashi hachiguro and Person of
Interest 431 John Taylor reason for
monitoring Person of Interest having
violated a American Neutrality Act and B
having set up an illegal State called
the attitude Republic of Polynesia along
with various other filibusters and
mercenaries current course of action
non-applicable former course of action
neutralized Person of Interest before
Person of Interest can attempt to either
disrupt Colonial interests in Polynesia
or under more severe circumstances
attempt to take over vast quantities of
land priority not applicable previously
High status dead previously president of
legal Republic henceforth referred to as
scp-4036 background information prior to
person of interest's relationship with
scp-4036 and other filibusters Person of
Interest developed an impactful if short
relationship with Person of Interest 182
William Walker in 1853 after Person of
Interest 182 was attempting to recruit
mercenaries to create the independent
federal republic Republic of sirona
October 1853 to May 1854 and the
Republic of lower California October
1853 to January 1854 as slave colonies
in the region however by 1854 the
relationship had declined between Person
of Interest 432 and 182 eventually
leading in Person of Interest 432 to
split from Person of Interest 182. by
1855 Person of Interest had heard
various stories about a Virgin Island in
the southern area of Polynesia filled
with resources such as sugar cane
tobacco and gold notably this region
purportedly contained a population that
had very little if any contact with
European explorers and was in the eyes
of most American filibusters at the time
servile in nature
in 1856 Person of Interest wrote to his
brother Person of Interest 431 John
Taylor who operated a private ship
building and trading service at the time
asking for a variety of ships for the
journey Person of Interest 431 delivered
the ships at a reduced charge for a
person of interest 432 but only under
the condition that he never contact him
again
by 1857 Person of Interest hired around
300 mercenaries and filibusters to come
with him in the total of 10 ships
outfitted with cannons and one year's
worth of food from the entire crew
Person of Interest then left for the
island it should be noted that person of
interest had no direct evidence of
scp-4036's existence as it only existed
in rumor in the California and Nevada
territories
the following documents have been
ordered sequentially in the order that
they were written
Walker ruined Sonora and Baja and is
currently ruining Nicaragua
he is an immoral slaver who believes
himself better than all others I tried
to force him in the right direction but
he would not listen to reason
this time things will be sufficiently
different we have weaponry we are away
from normal civilization and away from
the Americas of course other Colonial
powers are nearby but as long as we do
not anger them or gain their attention
all things will turn out well
Walker was crude in his presidential
style only ever focusing on slavery that
horrific barbaric institution it was a
fantasy as if they would be set Atop The
aristocracy instead of a rich Tennessean
it is a quite crude and a moral Venture
in my view
a yellow man an anthropologist who has
accompanied me on my voyage for the sake
of easy communication with these
tribesmen came to me in private
confidence to warn me about his
perceived fears over this project of
mine
I told him that such fears were not
justified we were both Republicans we
both believed slavery was immoral did he
not agree that it was the job of more
civilized people like us and the
Japanese to bring civilization to these
poor barbaric people to provide them the
tools and the resources to fight back
against tyranny exploitation of the Weak
and Powerless is inherent to The Human
Condition Cain slew able just for being
more pleasing in the eyes of our Lord
and savior four people on our planet and
we have our first murder the first time
blood was spilled upon the ground in the
pursuit of petty Revenge it is our job
to give these people some sort of equal
standing to have people defend them
the yellow man agreed and went back to
work
we reached the island I saw a woman in
the tree line matching the descriptions
of the natives she wore flesh-like
things on her body covering her below
the waist I'd almost say she was the
living image of beauty herself if the
abhorrent symbols didn't dot her face
and body
children destroying their bodies for the
sake of barbaric culture
we made Camp here and plan on keeping
Camp here for as long as necessary
I believe these natives would make fine
workers if we gain the Friendship of
their cultural institutions loyalty to
these institutions brings sacrifice for
the greater good great civilizations are
built on the back of good workers
to the east of this campsite I found a
small patch of dirt with queer
protrusions jutting from it it was hairy
but not like plant fuzz almost
animal-like in its physicality I felt an
instinctual urge to pull on it to see
what there was I ordered the men to help
me when I could not get it out myself
and together we managed to rip the plant
out of the ground
the protrusion was not a plant but a
tail the tail of a large swine we had
ripped its tail off how such a swine
came into existence on this
geographically isolated island I am
unsure as we got up we stared at the
creature it squealed in pain trying to
get itself up and walk but but it fell
back on its side and continued to bleed
and whimper as it laid dying I drew my
pistol and killed the poor thing I
looked over the corpse after killing it
it seemed fully grown
a scout team has returned to our camp
four men dead and three more injured
they testified that while searching for
natives a large 15-foot tall Beast Has
Come From The Greenery on the beach side
of the island mullets did nothing
against the bone Shields I ordered my
ships to scout the Beachside searching
for the Beast considering the
circumstances I believed it prudent
the Beast attacked our cap slaughtering
21 of our men that towered at least 19
feet with the majority of its face
surrounded by yellowy bone this creature
was foreign to me it had the Torso of a
mammoth the head of a horse and the
claws of a bear its torso was covered in
thick white bone and its claws made
entirely of Flesh they morphed and
changed like liquid
liquid metal
it tore through men slashing them apart
like Factory equipment with giant long
tendrils popping out of nowhere only to
be reabsorbed back into its body its
flesh almost looked like a spider's web
interconnecting into itself laying on
top of one another but it almost seemed
to be independent of the Beast trying to
force itself into a thousand different
directions but being stamped down by the
superior Force
some of our men got stuck inside just
touching it is enough to get stuck an
arm becomes your entire body I can still
hear the screams as those men were
consumed inside the mass of Flesh as
muffled as they were I felt its eyes
bore into me as our cannons tore through
its flesh leaving large holes in its
body
it still Twitches sometimes I need to
lay down or else I'll rip this page out
I plan on going into the middle of the
island and seeing if there are any
natives here I will take exactly 100
armed men there and see if we can come
to some sort of agreement with the
natives I wish to make good on my
promise to the Anthropologist and avoid
hurting as many as possible
I killed the chieftain today or what I
presume was a Chieftain he ordered us to
lay down our weapons at least from what
the Anthropologist told us I shoot him
in the head and he falls to the ground
without a single Yelp or whimper of pain
some ran in fear others too fearful to
run of which we captured and took back
to Camp the anthropologists and I hate
seeing the poor creatures in pain but
this is their fate for the time being
we talked to one of them a boy no older
than 10 he thanked us for killing the
chieftain for his rule was immoral and
cruel I received similar testimonies
from the others of this chieftain's
cruelty we told him we were going to
help them and make their lives better I
then asked him about the Beast and the
boy signed he told us that it was made
by The Village
the chieftain in response to seeing that
Outsiders had appeared on the island
ordered the entire tribe to group in the
main village and help construct a
guardian this process took the majority
of their energy but not three days later
the chieftain ordered the young Village
men to come with them and to fight the
Beast had been killed he said The
Chieftains said we were going to kill
the men and violate the women
the Anthropologist took me aside and
said that these villagers were an
anomaly I concurred as it was not normal
for people to craft flesh
but he said even aside from that this
shouldn't be possible
when I asked why he responded that this
language was a combination of European
and Polynesian languages along with that
these villagers didn't look like
Polynesians as their skin was light
toned unless they traveled across the
world to this island
some of the men brought us to this
Village it couldn't have been more than
300 men and women their houses weren't
made of wood or stone but masses of
Flesh which bulged and moaned these were
made from the bodies of the dead as a
way to make sure their deaths were not
worthless
they wore wet Flesh on themselves which
to me seemed more disgusting than the
houses themselves most of the village
was terrified of the chieftain not even
attempting to go back for the body
fearful that it wouldn't be dead some
were terrified of the new arrivals While
others asked the Elder who graciously
suggested they wait before jumping to
conclusions about their new guests the
majority followed the elders the sacred
group who had until very recently LED
their tribe
homelessness was non-existent they
seemed to have no Outsiders or
undesirables whether it be in a caste
system such as India or economic status
such as Europe and the rest of the
Americas men and women are not separated
based on sex but based on their nature
men and women hunt men and women search
for food they mostly subsist on meat but
fruits exist on this island as well I
saw families Rush from their houses to
some of the men we captured and
smothered them with kisses and hugs and
cries that they were okay and safe I saw
a man cry in front of another barely
standing up I asked kohashi what was
happening he said that they were
husbands
I wish to know nothing more I asked some
of the others if there was a village
Elder they said there were once many but
all of them were slaughtered by the
chieftain originally the island had been
run by wise old men who knew the
religion studied their practice since
birth and had their oral history since
the beginning of their tribe many
thousands of years ago
the chieftain originally an apprentice
of one of them rose up and killed them
along with the other apprentices he
mastered the Arts of crafting flesh at
an early age and could form entire
beasts in an instant I asked if there
was anyone else who could give me the
history of these people there was one
last remaining Elder
the chieftain's father
when I questioned them on where they
acquired the large mass of Flesh they
told me that in the quest to make the
Beast they had used up all their
reserves seeing an opportunity to make
right with the community I told them
that we had a large supply of food on
our ships and that if they needed to we
would provide them with as much food as
possible
however I needed an agreement from the
leader of this tribe they would agree to
whatever proposal I had if the Elder did
so who according to them would always
put their own interests aside for the
good of the village
we told him our offer which he accepted
and thanked us for being so generous he
hugged us and went out of the tent and
called for the entire Village saying
that the men would be generous and give
us food as they planted their own
our men transported food to them one
complained to me that they were giving
away their food I agreed but told him
that this was necessary to gain the
trust then once this occurred we would
be able to civilize them
we have established our Capital City
around the village we have been training
some of the hunters to hunt with our
rifles and they teach us their Homeland
and their agriculture they place a
newborn creature into the ground and
bury it the soil accelerates their
growth the Elder says this is a sign
from ion that the island is one of the
many holy lands they planted newborn
swines into the ground and will wait a
couple of months for them to develop
until then hunting other creatures such
as virgin's fish will be enough to fill
satisfy them I must remember to get cows
and chickens and normal pigs from my
newfound supplier swine is an excellent
dish but not something civilized people
should feed on
I had a thought many nights ago what if
I am meant to bring these people an
Empire
it is a strange thought but considering
everything that has gone on in the past
month is it so strange to think this is
there truth to this or at the very least
elements of Truth in it
I must think on this
I went into the mines today and these
Minds definitely have gold they could
probably go down many many miles down
below the crust of the earth I come from
a gold family it's in my bones even my
first job was mining gold so I know
there's gold here my men Whisper of
leaving with the gold
I cannot allow that to happen I must
create an economy here to strengthen
ourselves here assuming I have enough to
operate the mines I must have others
work on creating currency gold is
Humanity's oldest currency but these
people know nothing of money they don't
even have a barter economy instead
sharing with one another
I have heard of socialism among the
Europeans and this is the closest I can
think to socialism with few resources it
forces cooperation amongst them
it's beautiful in a way but not
conducive to a civilized society at
least in the economic sense I need to
solve the labor crisis before my men
forsake me
I asked the Elder a hypothetical
question
would it be possible for a human child
to be planted in the ground and for a
full adult to come in its place
he looked at me strangely
but he answered yes it is but it is
generally viewed as inhumane as it
destroys the lifespan of the child while
it is said in the past that in times of
disaster children will be planted this
is only done when no other possibility
is available
he then asked me why I was asking such
odd questions and I told him what I was
planning he seemed shocked at first
horrified even but then I described to
him our future plans
I told him I thought I was to be the
bringer of the Empire and that with our
weaponry and resources we bring it about
in quick order we brought him to the
gold mine and the ships and showed him
the maps of the world I told him that
together with these people's innate
abilities we could bring the entire
world under our Reign I described how
Commerce worked leaving out references
to competition as I know it would offend
his cultural sensibilities when I
described to him how Every Nation on
this planet had this and the necessity
of democratic institutions he seemed
more amicable to my plans
he approved of our plan but told us to
make it Swift and make sure the parents
do not witness this
almost to this he told the members of
the community that it is a moral
impotive to start producing Offspring as
soon as possible
ohashi looked at me with disdain
throughout the whole procedure
it's been nearly three months since my
last entry and I feel sick for what I've
done
I feel unclean nearly every woman on the
island is pregnant I feel disgusting I
cannot go into the village without
feeling disgusting I feel immoral I feel
evil I can see their faces I know what I
am I beg Christ's forgiveness and I know
he reviles me as well I threw my Bible
out to the Sea because I could feel it
berating me I could feel it berating me
for what I've done
but I need to do this I need to civilize
these people if I don't who will the
British the Americans any other horrible
immoral power that Slaughters its people
if I leave will the same befall these
children of nature I pray to a god whose
back is turned on me a child waved to me
today and I cried because I know that
child's brother will be the first one in
the ground
I threw up
I have sinned I am sin
it has been six months and I cannot
bring myself to reflect on my thoughts
anymore occasionally I'm plagued by
nightmares of children rising from the
ground and gnawing on me they're popping
out of the ground and grabbing me and
bringing me under I see myself having
dirt flung on me and they're still
grabbing with their tiny little hands
and crying for their mother
and I know I'm bleeding and I'm crying
out for God but God has turned his back
on me
it is done
the sin is done
I told some of the men to get their guns
oh Hashi as well he seemed disgusted at
himself he talked to himself in many
languages I didn't recognize I had never
seen him this way before the other man
began to get nervous the Elder of the
village told me that most of the
children were already born anywhere from
a couple of weeks to multiple months all
of sufficient age to be used the Elder
had performed his part I then ordered my
men to go into the tents and take the
children and not to shoot
I had to look away for most of it most
of the children were ripped from their
mothers and Father's arms as they cried
others tried to stab at us but were
beaten into submission one of our men
broke down he went into the tent and saw
a mother with her bone knife she held on
to her baby as tight as possible tears
running down her face she cried to ion
for him to save her son from these
Monsters the man began to cry himself
Jethro lost his son and daughter in the
blood disputes of Appalachia
he couldn't bring himself to fight back
and broke down
we had to have one of our men bring him
in and beat the mother into submission
she screamed for ION her Savior for
forgiveness of whatever sin she
committed to deserve this punishment she
begged she screamed eventually taking
one of our guns and shooting our man we
lost the child in the scuffle
she was put down
the Elder was attempting to console The
Village who had begged him for
assistance he wept it but told them it
was for the greater good for ION told
him that the Empire would come in time
due to this
until then do not resist for it may
anger iron
by the end of The Nightmare we had over
300 children we began the process of
burying them I can still hear their
cries
feeling the dirt and enter their bodies
and lungs and stomach
and everywhere else they will be birthed
soon
according to Legend the arm will be what
signifies the second birth
two weeks have passed and the men are
still Disturbed at the event many seek
to go home others Cry of nightmares I
feel something in my stomach weighing me
down I have this revolver next to me I
imagine myself putting the revolver in
my mouth and caulking the hammer and
shooting
may God take me from my mortal coil and
rip me apart I am a liar and a
disgusting fraud to all men
ohashi never speaks to me anymore only
sleeping and occasionally eating
the nightmares only get worse they're
not screaming anymore but Whispering
they're Whispering about what they will
do to me hundreds of voices whispering
in the black dirt around me holding on
to me and describing my death I will be
ripped apart by ion himself I am no more
civilized than the barbarians I'm trying
to save God please forgive me
I ruined the island
God I wish I could turn back turn back
and pretend none of this happened but if
I leave now the men will be angry for
all their time and effort is ruined not
only that but the island now relies on
my supplies it won't be for many months
if not years that their food stock will
be brought back up to its previous
circumstances if I do they're all going
to starve if I leave I will ruin these
people shown that the white man can't be
trusted and forever snap the connection
between us and Them
no I can't let this happen
I need to stay
I need to I am a monster I am
Unforgivable
I am sin itself
I am so sorry
it has been three months and there has
been a second birth
I stepped foot onto the Pastors in the
middle of the island for the first time
in three months limbs dotted the
landscape full-grown adult arms jotting
out of the ground covered in dirt and
sunburn some of my men have already
started pulling them out of the ground
the Elder tells me it takes a while
before full humans wake up
the women were placed into the care of
the village as they are necessary for
future reproduction and the men were
dropped off at the shipyard for future
mining Barracks have been built for them
and they will be taught how to mine and
fashion coinage for the island
we will repeat the process
I have written my Constitution I lifted
many aspects from the American one
most of the men despite many
reservations with me will vote for me in
the election
if I let the villagers vote I will
certainly lose these men know that
without me they'll certainly die without
the perceived friendship with ohashi
ohashi did not respond to me when I said
I wrote the Constitution
not that I blame them
I told the Elder that I won the
presidency and he congratulated me he
then asked how the second birthers were
I told them the mines were working at an
increased efficiency and that we are
creating the first batch of our currency
we opened the stores and gave each
villagers enough coin to buy a couple of
things we told them that if they wished
to continue this they would need to
accept the following to have their tent
destroyed and replaced with wooden
houses many of them rejected this as an
insult to their culture and that it
would make them selfish and
self-destructive we told them it was
either the house or the stores
many accepted although many of the older
members still refused by the end of the
day every tent was destroyed and
construction began
many of these men and women are hard
workers gold production is increasing
and even small farms are beginning but
yet I come across another problem
I need to rid these people of their
Collective Farms the collective Farm
makes it difficult to encourage
Enterprise because one must always think
the collective soil however I decided to
give the Elder plans about this and she
told me if it meant the Empire be
created faster so be it
I am sitting today I put down a Revolt
in the streets when I announced my plan
for the Farms to be split amongst the
best farmers in the community that
universally rejected it
they yelled at me and they began to
scream then they began to attack my men
one of my men Henry began to panic and
so drew his pistol and shot two men this
further inflamed the violence I called
ohashi to quell the violence but there
was nothing he could do they burned down
the store stealing things from inside
claiming that it was a violation of
their culture some even tried stealing
our guns I called in my men and they
began putting it down gunshots rang out
in the village eventually ending in the
death of 50 people
the Elder being one of them we put the
Revolt down a good fourth of our
original population was slaughtered in
the streets and by my men
God forgive me for what I've done I
called them barbarians killers and
thieves I killed a third of every man in
the city as I needed the women alive for
the birthing on the next day I took
every small child in the village and
buried them again the nightmares get
worse and worse but I know one thing I
will build my Empire
one bullet at a time
history
introduction of scp-4036 its history its
containment and its people
discovered force in Polynesia causing
Havoc across the smaller sparsely
populated Islands in Southeastern
Polynesia however since there was no
substantial proof of this it was
discarded
upon the invasion of the North Island in
June of 1861 the foundation could not
ignore this call for war within the day
of the initial Invasion the entire
Island fell to scp-4036 and its force of
5 000 men with a collective of 200 dead
after this the foundation declared
scp-4036 the top priority of the region
by the end of June the International
Coalition of Spain Japan Netherlands
France and Great Britain had been called
together by the foundation for the
purposes of combating this destructive
threat against the foundation and to a
greater extent Colonial interests in the
region
with General Beau leading forces in
South Island New Zealand the Coalition
began to force scp-4036 back however
despite conventional military wisdom
suggesting otherwise
scp-4036's forces were able to defeat
multiple attempts at Foundation
invasions of conquered territory the
attempted invasion of North Island
failed with over 1 000 Coalition
casualties mostly Japanese and British
all attempts at gaining the few isolated
pockets of scp-4036 had control of a
fail mostly due to a lack of
understanding of scp-4036's military
however one individual ohashi hashigoro
also known as Person of Interest 433
knew how to help vice president of
scp-4036 and leader of religious Affairs
he had an understanding of the culture
of scp-4036 that none could rival
even Taylor
writing 2052 a friend of ohashi before
his work with scp-4036 he offered the
foundation near unlimited information to
scp-4036's military operations their
tactics their weakness and if supplied
with armaments Rebel groups in the
region it was an offer the foundation
could not help but take advantage of and
the only thing ohashi wanted was that
scp-4036-1 the population the unharmed
the foundation in a remote island near
the main capital of scp-4036 delivered a
variety of armaments to ohashi and His
Rebel groups
however the decisive Factor was the
Battle of South Island
the Battle of South Island began on
October 13th when dozens of bone ships
were seen on the horizon their hulls
made entirely of femur bones made cannon
fire near impossible along with eyes
implanted on every part of the vessel
boarding them would also be impossible
preparing to defend the island General
Beau gave his men the order to hold
their ground
however in the background General Beau
came up with a different plan when the
o5 council gave him temporary level 5
status he had access to information a
normal General would not have been privy
to one of these was mobile task force
Theta 1 warhawks formed during the
foundation Civil War of 1814. theta 1
was composed of anomalous individuals
drawn from anomalous Persons of Interest
staff and scps the task force was made
up entirely of individuals who had
proven their loyalty to the foundation
during times of disaster they were
anything from combat operatives medical
officers memory wipers and spies they
were an Ace in the Hole so when General
Beau ordered them to destroy the fleet
they were only too glad to answer that
request
with a large thormic Blast from the sky
the flesh fleet was fried with no mercy
by the end of 1861
scp-4036 had been all but beaten
not only that it was near collapse
ohashi seeing an opportunity that the
Battle of South Island left open ordered
his Rebel groups to seize the day and
attacked the capital
within the span of two months from
December to January the capital was laid
to ruins the capital made up of over 20
000 citizens mostly military was reduced
to 3 000 by the end of the fighting
however despite the mass destruction
ashigoro was able to come out as the
vector declaring himself the president
of the Republic calling for elections of
the House of Representatives Senate and
for the church to call in delegates
Taylor realizing he had nothing left to
lose attempted one final assault on the
capital grabbing hold of the handful of
men still loyal to him he marched on the
Capitol Building ordering hashigoro his
former comrade to surrender and that he
would pardon him if he did ohashi
instead had his handful of men
slaughtered in the street and Taylor
himself gagged and placed into his own
private cell
ohashi knew that Taylor was leveraged
the Coalition however did not need
leverage most of the population had been
Thanks to Theta 1 pacified and the
damage is covered up the Coalition had
their colonies back and with minimal
damage it should have been sufficient
but it wasn't
the foundation still believing that
containment had not been fulfilled
pushed the coalition to invade the main
island however the Coalition unfamiliar
with Foundation policy were not willing
to plan a full-out invasion of the
island they were not willing to test
their militaries after near defeat mere
months ago
ohashi was also not willing to cooperate
he refused to allow Foundation
Representatives into the island and
ordered his military to arrest all
Foundation officers that arrived with no
way to combat this the foundation
resorted to containment of scp-4036
scp-4036 Remains the foundation's
biggest failure
modern
the following is a series of excerpts
from interviews of current day
scp-4036-1 these recordings were done
under the guise of a reporter from the
capital of scp-4036
oh yes I have I speak English
I'm not the best at it since it's
usually used by the the higher ones I
think that's the correct word again my
English is poor so I apologize for the
incorrect word yes I'm Japanese although
I haven't been to that country my father
sometimes talks about it but yeah I do
not know anything about the culture or
anything I intend to use English
sparingly only the city wants to reuse
it we use the traditional language the
ones our ancestors use to communicate
with Ayah before we were cut off
huh I told you yes since we use metal
our high priest ion Cuts us all from his
plush we are wandering in the dark now
we don't use those machines we use Flesh
and Bones like we always have and always
will use whenever I hold one of those
things in my hand I feel unclean in my
own skin I feel like a spirit massages
my skin and scalp and are horrifically
uncomfortable way
even talking about it makes me
uncomfortable
oh yes many of the farmers out here
don't use them but I think it's due to
their economy then their beliefs
the stories are if not the worst thing
I've ever seen at least up there in the
sheer quality of awfulness the pipes are
alive as well you see they grow and
expand upward and we need to encourage
it to go in the right direction you see
we got a couple limbs off here and there
sure that they scream and squeal but
they need to transport our waste in the
right direction you understand but that
ain't the worst part in my opinion the
worst part are the homeless Critters
underneath the city but don't bother
bringing the limbs back up a homeless
just eat it back up and yes those pints
are filled with our waste I do not know
how desperate a man must get before
eating piss and ship covered flesh but
that is desperation if I've ever seen
one
the foundation is a Scourge on this
planet
I find our president's rhetoric amoral
and perhaps dangerous does he not know
our history our past I don't understand
how we could platform on mending that
relationship it's like sticking your
dick in a beehive it might feel good for
a minute or two and then the stinging
happens it's just unpleasant the whole
way around
the president I uh I don't keep track of
what he does sorry English isn't first
language I am American I think but I
don't know much about it I know some
Japan language but I use the traditional
language it brings me closer with ir I
think the city dwellers are too
concerned with technology and metals and
with our savior or eye on but that is
not for me to decide or I'll absorbed
back into his body in the end anyways
I don't think the Christians and Muslims
deserve what happened to them but it is
unnatural for them to be here it isn't
natural for a European and Asiatic
religion to be on this island it spreads
far and fast and far beyond the eyes of
our government that think it's a danger
to our society now I don't think they
deserve what's going on for them by any
means but should they really be
surprised by what's going on it's
unregulated and clashes too wildly with
our culture we're a holy nation after
all founded on ion's beliefs and desires
not on Jesus or Muhammad no no no no no
no
violence I abhor violence I just want a
peaceful cleansing of the nation
that's all
I once went looking in the woods once I
heard they're murmuring their screams
I picked up my gun and traveled on foot
I Was preparing for one or two not a
dozen wearing large fleshy tendrils on
their persons they were wearing the
symbols of one of the nearby warlord
caps and so I began to walk away and
then fell into a bed I felt myself near
bodies Many Many Bodies dozens maybe a
hundred all in various states of radish
of worms crawling around in the eyes and
maggots eating holes inside the face in
the throating God knows where
my thought attracted to them I grabbed
my shotgun and hit under the bodies
praying to my savior for forgiveness and
to protect me from these barbaric
monsters
they spoke in hushed Whispers of the
traditional language one poke the body I
lay under I could smell her running
corpse her eyes weren't there anymore
just glassy holes that used to contain
Humanity a mother for one a sister for
another
a wife for another
I beat down and say they held flesh
Weaponry red black tendrils popping out
of their backs revealing their skeletons
and organs and everywhere else I aimed
for one of these backs hoping to strike
a harder mother vital organ I aimed and
fired owing not only his brains out but
his heart and his skeleton as well I ran
as far as possible occasionally firing
back as a warning their weapons were the
best in close range but were ineffective
in longer ranges I got inside my house
and didn't come out until morning I
slept with a shotgun I went to the
police that morning in the city they
checked the pit there wasn't a single
person whether a Christian or Islamic
iconography in that pet
the foundation is our protector as well
as our slaver it protects our borders
but only under the auspicious of keeping
us in bondage our military isn't for
protecting from other countries but from
an international agency bent on our
destruction
I've heard stories of attempts to court
the GOC and Gru but to no avail
I wonder if I'll never see my homeland
of Japan ever again but I doubt such a
possibility
our battle with the foundation isn't
only an ideological battle over
Independence and centralization
but a battle over science and religion
you see as the head of our church I
believe that the foundation is not only
a physical but spiritual Force
the foundation is the force that seeks
to contain who you are what you are they
wish to contain our religion keep it
from spreading as it should across the
world if we can destroy that Force
within us all that seeks to entain our
beliefs we've already won the battle
I sometimes worry that our people are
too focused on an upcoming defensive
battle with the foundation
the countryside wishes for peace in
their common religion while cities seek
outside corner such as phones on the
internet and other technological
equipment the foundation is a threat to
their religion and their ability to
connect to the outside I worked for the
military for two years and I can say we
all know a war's coming but we don't
want to admit it if there is a war our
country will burn I can assure you of
that
sometimes I wonder why we're here
of course I understand how we're here
but I don't know why we're here are we
just trying to keep the experiment our
founder had many years ago
of our second president or are we trying
to survive against the oppressive forces
of the foundation
I don't know I do know what we are at
least
enemies of the foundation and that binds
us together
for how much longer though I'm unsure
level 5 access only
think of Polynesia have come to the
following
that the attitude Republic of Polynesia
will be officially recognized by the
foundation and be allowed the conditions
of trade and self-determination on the
foundation supervision
at the foundation will to the best of
its abilities protect the regime of the
Republic its interests and its people at
the attitude Republic of Polynesia in
exchange for official status as an
anomalous state will in the case of
anomalous phenomenon relinquish all
responsibilities to the foundation when
captured
if there be an anomalous humanoid on the
appetite Republic of Polynesia outside
of standard anomalous capabilities see
article 3 for normalcy standards of the
Republic the erotic Republic authorities
will detain and revoke the citizenship
of said anomalous humanoid and place it
at the nearest Foundation site in the
region
allow the construction of site 4036 to
contain any anomalous objects entities
Etc that may inhabit the country
allow the foundation to use physical or
human resources in the region for the
purposes of furthering containment of an
item or serving Foundation needs
signed 05 1 2 4 5 6 8 9 10 11 12 13.
and president of the other type Republic
of Polynesia
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James sama
braided Peach
that loser
heroin sick
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
rubbish bin 69
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos found some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the vulgan
thank you
[Music]